so can we talk about
this kind of research and what's
actually done and what what are the
positives and negatives of it so
uh if we look again at function research
and the kind of stuff that's happening
level three and level four
bsl labs what's the whole idea here is
it trying to engineer
viruses to understand how they behave
you want to understand the dangerous
ones
yeah so that that would be the logic
behind doing it and so gain a function
can mean a lot of different things
viewed through a certain lens
gain-to-function research
could be what you do when you create you
know gmos
when you create you know hearty strains
of corn that are resistant to pesticides
i mean you could view that as gain of
function
so i'm going to refer to gain of
function in a relatively narrow sense
which is actually the sense
that the term is usually used which is
in some way
magnifying capabilities of
microorganisms
to make them more dangerous whether it's
more transmissible or more deadly
and in that line of research i'll use an
example from 2011
because it's very illustrative and it's
also very chilling
back in 2011 two separate
labs independently of one another i
assumed there was some kind of
communication between them but they were
basically independent projects one in
holland and one in wisconsin
um did gain a function research on
something called h5n1 flu
h5n1 is you know something that
at least on a lethality basis makes
kovid look like a kitten
you know covet according to the world
health organization has a case fatality
rate somewhere between half a percent
and one percent h5n1
is closer to sixty percent six zero and
so that's actually even slightly more
lethal than ebola it's a very very very
scary pathogen
the good news about h5n1 it is that it
is
barely barely contagious and i believe
it is in no way contagious human to
human it requires
um you know very very very deep contact
uh with birds in most cases chickens
and so if you're a chicken farmer and
you spend an enormous amount of time
around them and perhaps you get into
situations in which you get a break in
your skin and you're interacting
intensely with with foul who
as it turns out have h5n1 that's when
the jump comes
but it's not there's no airborne
transmission that we're aware of human
to human i mean they're
not that way it just doesn't exist um i
think the
world health organization did a
relentless survey of the number of h5n1
cases i think they do it every year i
saw one 10-year series
where i think it was like 500 fatalities
over the course of a decade
and that's a drop in the bucket kind of
fun fun fact
i believe the typical lethality from
lightning over 10 years is 70 000
deaths so we've been getting struck by
lightning pretty low risk h5n1
much much lower than that what happened
in these experiments
is the experimenters in both cases
set out to make h5n1 that would be
contagious
that could create airborne transmission
and so they basically passed it i think
in both cases they passed it through
a large number of ferrets and so this
wasn't like
crispr there wasn't even a crispr back
in those days this was relatively
straightforward you know selecting for a
particular outcome
and after guiding the path and passing
them through
again i believe it was a series of
ferrets they did in fact come up with
a version of h5n1 that is capable of
airborne transmission
now they didn't unleash it into the
world they didn't
inject it into humans to see what would
happen and so for those two reasons we
don't
really know how contagious it might have
been
but you know if it was as contagious as
covid
that could be a civilization threatening
pathogen
and why would you do it well the people
who did it were good guys
they were virologists i believe their
agendas they explained it was
much as you said let's figure out what a
worst case scenario
might look like so we could understand
it better but
my understanding is in both cases it was
done in by bsl3 labs
and so potential of leak
significantly non-zero hopefully way
below one percent but significantly
non-zero
and when you look at the consequences of
an escape in terms of human lives
destruction of a large portion of the
economy etc and you do an expected value
calculation
on whatever fraction of one percent that
was you would come up with
a staggering cost staggering expected
cost for this work so it should never
it should never have been carried out
now you might make an argument
if you said if you believed that h5n1
in nature is on an inevitable path
to airborne transmission and it's only
going to be a small number of years
a and b if it makes that transition
there is you know one set of changes to
its metabolic pathways
and you know it's genomic code and so
forth one
that we have discovered so it is going
to go from point a which is where it is
right now to point b
we have reliably engineered point b that
is the destination
and we need to start fighting that right
now because this is five years or less
away
now that'd be very different world
that'd be like spotting an asteroid
that's coming toward the earth and it's
five years off and yes you marshal
everything you can to resist that but
there's two problems with that
perspective
the first is in however many thousands
of generations that humans have been
inhabiting this planet there has
never been a transmissible form of h5n1
and influenza has been around for a very
long time
so there is no case for inevitability
of this kind of a jump to airborne
transmission so
we're not on a freight train to that
outcome and if there was inevitability
around that
it's not like there's just one set of
genetic code that would get there
they're just there's there's all kinds
of different mutations
that could conceivably result in that
kind of an outcome
unbelievable diversity of mutations and
so we're not actually creating something
we're inevitably going to face
but we are creating something we are
creating
a very powerful and unbelievably
negative card and injecting in the deck
that nature never put into the deck so
in that case
um i just don't see any moral or
scientific
justification for that kind of work and
interestingly
there was um quite a bit of excitement
and concern about this when the work
came out one of the teams was going to
publish their results in science the
other in nature
and there were a lot of editorials and a
lot of scientists are saying this is
crazy
and publication of those papers did get
suspended
and not long after that there was a
pause put on u.s government funding nih
funding on gain of function research
but both of those speed bumps were
ultimately uh removed
those papers did ultimately get
published and that pause on funding
you know ceased long ago and in fact
those two very projects my understanding
has
resumed their funding got their
government funding back i don't know why
a dutch project's getting nih funding
but whatever
about a year and a half ago so as far as
the u.s government and regulators are
concerned
it's also systems go for gain of
function at this point which i
i find very troubling now i'm a little
bit of an outsider from this field but
it has echoes of the same kind of
problem i see in the ai world
with autonomous weapon systems nobody
in my colleagues my colleagues
friends as far as i can tell people in
the ai community
are not really talking about autonomous
weapons systems
as now us and china are full steam ahead
on the development of both
right and that seems to be a similar
kind of thing on getting a function
i've uh you know have friends in the
biology space
and they don't want to talk about gain
of function
publicly it and i don't that makes me
very uncomfortable
from an outsider perspective in terms of
gain of function it makes me
very uncomfortable from the insider
perspective on autonomous weapon systems
i'm not sure how to communicate exactly
about autonomous weapon systems and i
certainly don't know how to communicate
effectively about
gain a function what is the right path
forward here
should we seize all gain of function
research is that
is that really the solution here well
again i'm going to use gain of function
in the relatively narrow
context of overview because you could
say almost you know anything that you do
to make biology more effective is gain a
function so within the narrow confines
of what we're discussing
i think it would be easy enough
for level-headed people in all of the
countries level how many governmental
people and all the countries that
realistically could support such a
program to agree
we don't want this to happen because all
labs leak i mean and you know an example
that i
i use actually didn't use in the piece i
did with sam
harris as well um is the anthrax attacks
in the united states in 2001. i mean
talk about an example of the least
likely lab
leaking into the least likely place uh
shortly after 9 11 for folks who don't
remember it and
it was a very very lethal strand of
anthrax that
as it turned out based on the for
forensic genomic work that was done and
so forth
absolutely leaked from a high security
u.s army lab
probably the one at fort detrick and
maryland it might have been another one
but who cares
it absolutely leaked from a high
security u.s
army lab and where did it leak to this
highly
dangerous substance that was kept under
lock and key by a very security-minded
organization
well it leaked to places including the
senate majority leader's office tom
daschle's office
i think it was senator leahy's office
certain publications including
bizarrely the national enquirer but
let's go to the senate majority leader's
office it is hard to imagine
a more security-minded country than the
united states two weeks after the 911
attack i mean you it doesn't get more
security-minded than that
and it's also hard to imagine a more
security
capable organization than the united
states military
we can joke all we want about
inefficiencies in the military and you
know
24 000 wrenches and so forth but pretty
capable when it comes to that and
despite
that level of focus and concern and
competence
just a days after the 9 11 attacks
something comes from the
inside of our military industrial
compacts and ends up
you know in the office of someone i
believe the senate majority leader
somewhere in the line of presidential
succession
it tells us everything in league so
again think of a level-headed
conversation
between powerful leaders in a diversity
of countries
thinking through like i can imagine a
very simple powerpoint revealing
you know just discussing briefly things
like the anthrax leak
um things like uh this this foot and
mouth disease
outbreak that or leaking that came out
of a bsl four level lab
in the uk several other things talking
about
the utter virulence that could result
from gain of function and say
folks can we agree that this just
shouldn't happen
i mean if we were able to agree on the
nuclear nonproliferation treaty which we
were
bioweapons convention which we did agree
on we the world
for the most part i believe agreement
could be found
there but it's going to take people in
leadership
of a couple of very powerful countries
to get to consensus amongst them
and then to decide we're going to get
everybody together and browbeat them
into banning this stuff now that doesn't
make it entirely impossible that
somebody might do this
but in well-regulated you know
carefully watched over fiduciary
environments
like federally funded academic research
anything going on in the government
itself
you know things going on in you know
companies that have
investors who don't want to go to jail
for the rest of their lives
i think that would have a major major
dampening impact on it
you